hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and this one i plan on
showing you guys uh how to download and
install google chrome 3.0 themes and uh
if you haven't noticed already that uh
google chrome 3.0 release has come out
you can download the beta if you will at
the link in the description uh whatever
side that's on if i apologize but you
can download that at the link in the
description basically it'll take you
and it'll basically just download and
install google chrome restart google
chrome and it'll be 3.0 now how will you
know you have 3.0 just go ahead and
click on that uh wrench in the top right
hand corner go to options and you'll be
able to see under basics if um i'm sorry
not options if you right click on the
wrench and go to about google chrome
it'll tell you what version you have and
here i have version 3.0
so what we're going to do is uh just go
through the themes and basically how you
install google chrome themes is
extremely simple i love the way google
makes this so uh so easy with their
browser
so i'm just going to go ahead and show
you guys how to do this real quick okay
you click on the wrench and go ahead and
go down to options like i did before
and you can go under the personal stuff
tab in the top middle and down on the
right hand side you see this get themes
button so the default theme is the theme
that i'm running right now you can see
with windows vista uh home premium
64-bit i do have um
arrow running so go ahead and hit get
themes and here it'll take you to this
link
tools.google.com chrome with all the
themes that you can install i'll go
ahead and maximize this here these are
all the themes that you can install
uh so far by google uh for chrome so the
one that i like the best is actually uh
the grayscale one which you know isn't a
big deal you can apply any of these
themes all you have to do to apply the
theme i'm going to uh shrink this window
again all you have to do to apply it is
hit that apply theme button now if you
watch as i click this i'm going to zoom
back out to full screen for you guys
and i'm probably going to fade away my
picture in picture but if you watch as i
apply this it'll very quickly download
the theme and install the theme throw in
the c program files and google chrome
and everything and install it just like
that so watch apply theme
and just like that it has restarted fire
restarted uh google chrome it has done
everything you would have to do in the
normal steps uh to install a firefox
theme in one button press so now i'm
actually using the google chrome 3.0
grayscale theme pretty good
youtube there it is so i mean this is
really really simple the way they um the
way they throw it in there basically i
think it's awesome that they can just
make it that simple
so yeah that is it guys you can uh
uninstall the theme at any time just by
going back to the options and going into
get themes and see here it says reset to
default theme you can click that or you
can go into get themes and then
obviously apply the classic theme which
happens to be the one uh the default
theme so that is it guys that is it for
uh google chrome 3.0 themes i hope this
video was helpful to you guys i hope you
learned whatever you need to know about
google chrome 3.0 themes and if you do
have any other video tutorial ideas or
requests just go ahead and send me a
message or leave a comment below anyway
thanks for watching that is it guys and
i'll catch you guys in the next video
peace